normally my prospects have coming back
alive from a meeting with nikki were 99
out of a hundred
but this time when i heard him say a
couple of hundred yards down the road
i gave myself 50 50.
[Music]
where the [ __ ] you get off talking to
people about me behind my back going
over my head what people what people
would you think i wasn't gonna find out
i don't even know what you're talking
about nick no you said i'm bringing heat
on you i gotta listen to people because
of your [ __ ] [ __ ] you're ordering me
out you better get your own [ __ ] army
pal i didn't do anything i mean i didn't
order you or anybody i only told andy
stone that you had a lot of heat on you
and that was a problem you want me to
get out of my own [ __ ] town yeah i
said i'll let the [ __ ] blow over for
a while so i can run the casino anything
goes wrong with the casino it's my ass
it's not yours it's my ass uh i don't
know whether you know this or not but
you only have your [ __ ] casino
because i made that possible i'm what
counts out here not your [ __ ] country
clubs or your [ __ ] tv shows and what
the [ __ ] are you doing on tv anyhow you
know i get calls from back home every
[ __ ] day they think you wear bad [ __ ]
i'm only on tv because i got to be able
to hang around the casino you understand
that you know that [ __ ] yes you could
have had the food and beverage job
without going on television you wanted
to go on tv yeah i did want to go on tv
that way i have a forum i can fight back
i'm known people see me they know they
can't [ __ ] around with me like they
could if i was an unknown that's right a
big [ __ ] spectacle of yourself me i
wouldn't even be in this situation if it
wasn't for you you brought down so much
[ __ ] heat on me i mean every time i
meet somebody here the big question is
do i know you oh sure i don't want to
bring your [ __ ] license on me
nikki when you asked me if you could
come out here what did i tell you i mean
you asked me and i knew you're going to
come out no matter what i said but what
did i tell you do you remember what i
told you do you remember what i told you
a minute here one minute i asked you
when the [ __ ] did i ever ask you if i
could come out here get this through
your head get this through your head you
jew [ __ ] you you only exist out
here because of me that's the only
reason without me you personally every
[ __ ] wise guy still around i'll take
a piece of your [ __ ] jew ass that way
you're gonna go you're [ __ ] warren
don't ever go over my [ __ ] head again
you [ __ ] you
[Applause]
you